[Applaus]
[Musik]
Kolumbien ist ein Land der zwei
Gesichter leider können wir an die
schlechte Seite nur zu gut Drogenbarone
Terrorismus und Armut aber es hat auch
eine andere viel bessere Seite du fragst
hier sicher welche die sein könntet nur
du wirst wahrscheinlich überrascht sein
ist die Wirtschaft Kolumbien ist ein der
stabilsten Volkswirtschaften ganz
Lateinamerikas
[Musik]
und nicht nur dass es steht geradezu als
Positivbeispiel heraus du hat Kolumbien
z.b. eine Hyperinflation erlebt und
verfügt über die beste startkredit
Historie in ganz Lateinamerika
[Musik]
Seite 130 hat die kolumbianische
Regierung ihre Schulden zurückgezahlt
und ja ich weiß das wäre nicht besonders
spektakulär wenn wir über den
Europäischen sprechen würden aber heute
sind wir eben in Lateinamerika und im
Vergleich zu Venezuela Argentinien
Brasilien oder Mexiko Kolumbien gar
nicht so schlecht aus das hat sich
jedoch mit der Corona geändert Kolumbien
am stärksten betroffenen
Steuererhöhungen
wieder
hervorgerufen und wenn ich massiv sage
ist dass die blanke Untertreibung
tatsächlich handelt sich um eine
in Kolumbien steigt Zahl der Toten bei
den Protesten gegen Präsident ok auf 47
[Musik]
die einen sagen die kolumbianische
Polizei sei nichts als eine brutale
Schlägertruppe die Gegenseite behaupten
das gleiche aber in Bezug auf die
Demonstranten kolumbianische Politiker
wieder
gehen sogar soweit zu behaupten dass
bestimmte terroristische Gruppierungen
dem Protest infiltriert
kristallisiert haben aber Moment mal ist
dies nicht ein Argument welches in
letzter Zeit bei allen Arten von
Protesten gegen Regierungen weltweit in
Mode gekommen ist wieso Gerät gerade
jetzt dieses wichtige demokratischen
Instrument das Bürgerrecht auf
Demonstration unter Beschuss wieso wird
es von manchen als große Gefahr
diskreditiert oft erkennt man den wahren
Kern der Dinge erst wenn man sie aus
einer Distanz betrachtet und deswegen
wollen wir heute die Ursachen dieser
Entwicklung konkret in Kolumbien klären
wer also hat
Regierung von Ivan du auf Teufel komm
raus die Steuern und warum spielt die
Damaskus in eine so wichtige Rolle in
dieser Damaskus was bitteschön also
heute werden wir all diese Fragen
natürlich beantworten aber zuerst genau
zuerst lasst uns zum besseren
Verständnis einen schnellen Blick in die
Geschichte werfen
[Musik]
das Loch nach der Bunny ich werde dir
jetzt eine kleine Frage stellen und ich
bin mir hundertpro sicher dass du nicht
wissen wirst wie du mir antworten sollst
wie viele Menschen zahlen in Kolumbien
Einkommensteuer okay ich werde es ja
sein wie ein paar Tipps geben also reden
hier über eines der
bevölkerungsreichsten Länder
Lateinamerikas über 50 Millionen
Einkommensteuer zahlen
natürlich
ich gemacht habe
[Musik]
zukommt die grassierende politische
Korruption jedes Jahr Milliarden von
Dollar verschlägt dir vorstellen kannst
Situation sehr schwierig steuern auf
herkömmliche Art und Weise einzutreiben
[Musik]
und du fragst Dich wahrscheinlich woher
bekommt der kolumbianische Startern
eigentlich das Geld welches er zur
Finanzierung des ganzen Staatswesens
braucht nun im Grunde versucht er es
nicht zu beschaffen wo immer er kann wie
ein Junkie eben da sie ja keine
regulären Einkommen bestellen können hat
Kolumbien
Lateinamerika
covid-19
europe
[Musik]
ist es ein Problem auf der einen Seite
will die Regierung von Ivan Duque die
Unternehmen Steuern senken und damit
neue Sektoren des Lebens zu schaffen auf
der anderen Seite muss sie nach neuen
Wegen suchen um die Einnahmen zu erhöhen
mit anderen Worten Kolumbien ein
gewaltiges Loch in seinem Haushalt der
Schulden zu bedienen
cronaca jedem Land der Welt wo Auslöser
nie dagewesenen staatlichen Ausgaben
[Musik]
die öffentlichen Ausgaben während der
vermieten Kolumbien belaufen sich auf
34,6
[Musik]
Grund in Sunline Landrat zu behandelt
als hätten sie Schrott Status
gehen durch die Decke und die brauchen
desto mehr Zinsen müssen sie dafür
zahlen noch so ein Exponentialkurve
[Musik]
ja und hier kommt der kontroversesten
ins Spiel denn zweitens wenn du Quai
ausgerechnet die Steuern für den
Mittelschicht erhöhen der bisherige
monatliche Freibetrag für die
Einkommensteuer betrug
4700000 kolumbianische Pesos umgerechnet
2000 € nur wer also mehr als 1000 € im
Monat verdient es wurde vom Fiskus zur
Kasse gebeten du cable mit seiner Reform
diesen Freibetrag auf weniger als die
Hälfte 2,3 Millionen Jesus also rund 500
€ absenken und
wenn man noch die aktuelle die Höhe
schießen Inflation also sozusagen die
kalte Absenkung der Freibeträge zunimmt
ist es eine gigantische Mehrbelastung
für mittlere Einkommen aber das ist noch
nicht alles nicht bereit sind habe hat
Kolumbien einige höchsten Steuern in
Lateinamerika allerdings gibt es eine
Menge Produkte die Ermäßigungen haben
fast alle diese Steuersätze erhöhen
Computer die mit dem % besteuert werden
soll aber auch die
Milch oder die bisher steuerfrei waren
und nur mit 5% besteuert werden soll und
hier kommt die große Kontroverse
Endspiel
Edelstein betreffen vor allem die Mittel
und Unterschicht diese würden immer mehr
ausgesaugt während die Reichen
ungeschoren davon Kind und das ist es
was die ersten Proteste auslöste aber
was geschah danach nun das werden wir
uns mal genauer anschauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Kolumbien Apple die Zahl der Toten bei
den Protest gegen Präsident ok auch 47
zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung des Videos
lag die Zahl der durch die Polizei im
Bereich bei 68 und die darüber 200 die
gefürchtete kolumbianische
Momente
gibt es keine schwarze
Polizei gegen Demonstranten
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
zwei Tote und fast hundert verletzte
Polizisten bei Protesten in Kolumbien
wegen Steuerreform
The und Unruhen mit anderen Worten es
ist eine Waffe die entwickelt wurden zu
stoppen ohne sie zu töten was ist also
das Problem nun eigentlich sind diese
Raketen dazu konzipiert auf einer
parabolischen Bahn also in einem Bogen
erschossen zu werden es geht Dir doch
mehrere Befehle in den die Polizei diese
Waffe benutzt hat um damit direkt auf
Bürger zu schießen und in diesen Fällen
kann das wenn man tödlich sein du fragst
Dich also wahrscheinlich warum kommt es
zu diesen Exzessen wieso ist die
kolumbianische Polizei so gewalttätig
hier kommen wir zum wirklich
interessanten Videos mach dich
überraschen aber es gibt mehr colombiana
mit Schusswaffen als Kolumbianer die
Einkommensteuer
anrechnen fast fünf Millionen
Kolumbianer illegale Schusswaffen die
Folge davon 1 nicht
nur von Drogenhändlern gucken
dass ich unter den Demonstranten
welche durch diese Gruppe
haben Sie also recht jetzigen Zeitpunkt
können wir nicht bestätigen aber es
handelt sich nicht um eine völlig
abwegige Theorie Terrorgruppen
verschwinden nicht übernachten
einige Mitglieder dieser Gruppen
angeschlossen haben könnten das erklärt
warum die kolumbianische Polizei der
Armee als einer normal Polizei Edith und
dann ich übertreibe nicht im geringsten
in fast jedem
Ministerium
[Musik]
mehr als tausend Bilderstreit kackt und
des Heeres werden eintreffen um die
Sicherheit in Kali zu stärken
und das ist der Punkt an dem wir in die
ewige Debatte eintreten können wer im
Recht ist die Polizei und die
Antwort ist wieder noch mal darüber nach
die Aufgabe der Polizei ist doch die
Sicherheit der Bürger zu gewährleisten
zu schützen und die Bösen zu stoppen
dass ich das genaue Gegenteil abspielen
immer noch die Straßen und machen
Kolumbien Länder der Welt
und genau das werden wir uns jetzt
anschauen
[Musik]
die Damaskus doch Trainer schon gesagt
haben marschieren in Kolumbien und
also in der kolumbianischen
nur auf eine Sache ausgerichtet ist
spezialoperation
vielleicht nun eine Militärdoktrin ist
Einsatz von Handtüchern Prozessen
Strategien und Taktiken nach der richtet
mit anderen Worten eine
spontane Entscheidung aus dem Bauch raus
alle Entscheidungen
standardisiert festgelegt auf diese
Weise
erklärt
[Musik]
Oldie billig Demonstranten anzugreifen
erklärt wie man Soldaten trainiert um
Menschenrechtsverletzungen zu vermeiden
mit anderen Worten wie man riskante
Situationen lösen zu müssen wenn ich für
ein Moment in
einem Menschen gibt
[Musik]
General Zapatero wurde trotz Skandals
als Armee Kommandant vereidigt
in der
2000er
und dieser Mann ist dafür verantwortlich
dass er
gekommen ist
ihr Bürgerrecht auf friedlichen Protest
zum Ausdruck demokratische Legitimierung
zu schützen Beispiel indem radikale
Mitläufer weil die Proteste für Agenda
missbrauchen wollen isoliert werden und
ganz deutlich von den friedlichen
Demonstranten werden ja dafür gibt es
erprobte und standardisierten
Vorgehensweise aber wurde nicht
angewendet da ihre Einführung im Rahmen
einer
viertel und
gefährdet hätte dann
einfach in
einen Krieg eskaliert ist ein Krieg der
nicht mehr zu stoppen sein wird deswegen
ist die Frage
denkst du dass die
[Musik]